voilà une excellente nouvelle le
gouvernement vient de mettre en ligne
l'attestation de sortie de chez vous sur
smartphone n'est plus besoin elle l'a
remplie dans un pdf ou de l'imprimé pour
la présente version papier vous pouvez
la voir directement dans votre
smartphone donc ça c'est bien ça va
économiser quelques feuilles blanches à
la sauver la planète
donc ça croyez moi c'est bien qu'ils
donc vous guider dans cette vidéo papa
pour vous montrer comment utiliser cette
attestation sur smartphone je vais faire
sur un os en utilisant un iphone on se
promet axe mais je veux également le
faire sur android en utilisant le
dernier shah au mileu milices pro vous
allez voir c'est pas très compliqué si
vous arrivez sur la chaîne et que vous
connaissez pas je m'appelle monsieur
heureux je présente toute l'actualité
tech et notamment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup smartphone je vous
êtes je vous conseille ce soit pour du
smartphone d ordre d'idée monde
compagnie ci et ça donc c'est pas des
charges et invite dès maintenant à vous
abonner comme ça vous saurez tout sur
l'actu tech et pour commencer on déroge
pas à la règle pendant tout le
confinement je vous ai demandé de
m'envoyer vos vidéos chez vous savoir
comment ça se passe et si ça allait bien
pour vous pouvez donc toujours mais
renvoyé ici à l'adresse qui apparaît
amour @ monsieur leur point fr ou
envoyez votre petite vidéo on l'a
partagée aujourd'hui la vidéo du jour
donc après avoir fait les devoirs les
petits bijoux pendant papa il regarde de
monsieur vrai courage à tout le monde en
cette période de confinement on sait que
pour certains qui son appartement c'est
pas facile on a la chance d'être en
maison
donc voilà plein de courage à tout le
monde à toute la famille moi quoique
joyeux repas thé vidéo sur la je me pose
le soir sur le canapé le vidéoprojecteur
et je descends l'écran voilà courage à
tout le monde merci à tous d'avoir
envoyé la vidéo maintenant le regarder
directement comment ça marche pour avoir
cette attestation sur smartphone comment
l'utiliser comment l'enregistrer pour
pouvoir la présenter en cas de contrôle
on va commencer par attestation sur ios
vous allez voir ce extrêmement savent ce
qu'il faut faire c'est souvent sur le
lien que je vous indique en bas en
balade dans la description vous cliquez
dessus c'est très simple vous arrivez
sur l'attestation à remplir directement
sur votre smartphone vous auriez donc il
faut la remplir aux lignes on va la
remplir en ligne on va remplir des
informations de base prénom moi c'est
aurélien non c'est gran et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à tous d'être de naissance
on va se mettre n'importe quoi 1er
janvier 1990 pas du tout ma date de
naissance en êtes pas obligé de me
croyez pas lieu de naissance je suis né
à clermont
rend clairement vous l'écrire et comme
vous voulez au tac
voilà adresse allez on va dire que
j'habite 1 2 aller si on veut 2 avenue
foch à paris ce qui est complètement
faux je n'habite pas du tout avenue foch
à paris
mais c'est juste pour illustrer le
propos vive allez paris pareil tac tac
tac code postal à 75001 est sympa très
très bien on va faire ça choisissez un
motif de sortie alors soit exactement la
même chose que les motifs que vous
retrouvez sur l'attestation que vous
allez imprimer le premier motif c'est
pour l'exercice professionnel si vous
devez sortir pour aller à votre travail
le deuxième c'est pour aller faire des
achats de première nécessité le
troisième c'est pour des soins allez
voir votre médecin et des soins et c'est
le 3e c'est pour des déplacements motifs
impérieux familiaux pour aller aider un
membre de votre famille qui ne
pourraient pas faire par lui-même
et puis dernier ses déplacements bref
dans la limite d'une heure quotidienne
rosario mixmania km en gros sortir au
tour si vous pour vous dégourdir les
pattes avant dernière convocation
judiciaire ou administrative et la
dernière c'est la participation à des
missions d'intérêt général sur demande
des autorités administratives allez on
va dire que nous on sort un petit peu ça
irait parce que nous on n'en peut plus
hop aph
on clique date de sortie champ de cette
vidéo le jour effectivement où ils ont
montré cette attestation pour
smartphones le 6 avril heure de sortie
bien on va dire allez on va dire qu'on
sera 10 heures on prend un petit peu
d'avancé pour la vidéo et les 9 heures
et quelques allez hop 10h tac up hockey
généré mon attestation on clique dessus
ça va donc vous générez un pdf vous est
donc retrouver votre attestation comme
vous la trouviez sur papier tout sera
rempli par rapport à ce que vous avez
rempli ya c'est extrêmement simple vous
et combattre la première fois que vous
avez un qr code qui peuvent scanner par
les forces de l'ordre et sur la deuxième
faille vous allez le qr code
en gros beaucoup plus facile à se caler
ce qu'il faut faire maintenant c'est
enregistré cette attestation parce que
si vous la conserver comme ça en l'état
dans votre navigateur
et que pour une raison ou pour une autre
vous la fermez vous n'aurez plus et vous
ne pourrez pas la présenter en cas de
contrôle et la voudrait quand même
relativement bt ça mérite quand même une
amende de 135 euros ça il faut le savoir
et vous allez venir l'enregistrer en bas
dans ce fichier vous cliquez sur
enregistrer dans ce fichier sur le club
ou sur votre iphone enregistré là sur
votre iphone si vous n'avez pas accés
internet pour quelques raisons que ce
soit au moins vous l'avez en dur dans
votre iphone ça évitera les problèmes
moi j'ai créé un vide aussi attestations
et la petite icône en haut vous aussi
vous voulez un peu importe à les
attestations jeu là les là je clique sur
panne ça me donne le nombre des stations
je vais marquer par exemple
10 matin voilà comme ça j'ai nommé
attestation pour lundi matin
je termine je le registre bien dans
l'attestation je clique sur enregistrer
et là elle est enregistrée ensuite c'est
très simple je vais dans fichiers sur
mon iphone j'ai tous mes dossiers sur
mon iphone depuis son dossier
attestations et l'âge sur l'attestation
lundi matin je clique et là je peux la
présente et très facilement aux forces
de l'ordre
et ça c'est vachement mer ce qu'on ne
sait pas venir scanner et vous pouvez
vers autant l'attestation de vous voulez
alors il était d'en abuser éviter de
corps des attestations lorsque vous
allez sortir une heure puis encore une
heure après plus encore une heure après
franchement c'est pas très fermé au
moins vous pouvez les avoir c'est
beaucoup plus simple si vous savez que
vous devez sortir cet après midi pour
aller faire des courses et bien fait le
lendemain vous allez sortir de telle
heure à telle heure pour les couvrir
on pouvait l'anticiper protestation sur
android c'est exactement la même chose
ou pas pu se passer par le lien que vous
aimiez en bas vous remplissez vos
documents de la même manière alors on va
recommencer aurait lien nos g né voilà
date de naissance 010 1992
allez on change lieu de naissance
toujours une à clermont ferrand ça ne
change pas par contre adresse à les deux
avenues foch une fois de plus ce n'est
pas mon adresse je n'habite pas avenue
foch sont pas du tout les moyens à paris
75001 je suis d'accord choisissez la
sortie eh bien cette fois ci on va
sortir aller par exemple n'est pas ce
moment bref on va sortir pour aller
faire quelques achats
on a fait faire des courses on point nos
frigos et on sort cette fois ci tac
eh bien on va sortir à 10h30 cette année
ce n'est pas très très bien déplacement
je clique sur généré mon attestation
sanhadja l'air exactement de la même
manière
l'attestation été téléchargé sur votre
appareil la voyez c'est beaucoup plus
simple je sors de là sur vos smartphones
android ce que vous faites vous avez
dans votre gestionnaire fichiers là où
tous vos fichiers vont être enregistrées
par exemple ici gestoni un fichier je
clique dans metal est téléchargement de
l'attestation je peux aussi aller dans
le dossier téléchargements je clique sur
attestations et là je trouve
l'attestation dérogatoire de la même
manière je la trouvais sur mon
smartphone ios fut donc mon qr code
elle est enregistrée je peux la
présenter en cas de contrôle ballon pour
ce tuto pour cette attestation j'espère
que ça vous aura aidé c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à laisser un joli poussent
vers le haut je vous invite
évidemment à vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas vous avez le bouton qui
situent juste là vous cliquez vous
abonner comme ça vous saurez tout sur la
culture sur ce je vous embrasse pour
deux rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer par mt à calais des bisous et
à demain
ciao
[Musique]